an act of omission, of shallowness,
the sin of anger, the sin of self-pity,
trying to be a people-pleaser, a lack of courage.
Adam I is built by building on your strengths.
Adam II is built by fighting your weaknesses.
You go into yourself, you find the sin
which you've committed over and again through your life,
your signature sin
out of which the others emerge,
and you fight that sin and you wrestle with that sin,
and out of that wrestling, that suffering,
then a depth of character is constructed.
And we're often not taught to recognize
the sin in ourselves,
in that we're not taught in this culture
how to wrestle with it,
how to confront it, and how to combat it.
We live in a culture with an Adam I mentality
where we're inarticulate about Adam II.
Finally, Reinhold Niebuhr
summed up the confrontation, the fully lived
Adam I and Adam II life, this way:
"Nothing that is worth doing can be achieved in our lifetime;
therefore we must be saved by hope.
Nothing which is true or beautiful or good makes
complete sense in any immediate context of history;
therefore we must be saved by faith.
Nothing we do, however virtuous, can be accomplished alone;
therefore we must be saved by love.
No virtuous act is quite as virtuous
from the standpoint of our friend or foe as from our own standpoint.
Therefore we must be saved by that final form of love,
which is forgiveness.”
Thanks.
(Applause)